♪ ♪
>> Tucker: SPENT HIS LIFE
CHAMPIONING ORDINARY PEOPLE AND
NOT EVERYONE IS EVERYONE IS
APPRECIATED.
NARRATING THE NEW SEASON OF THE
DISCOVERY CHANNEL HOW THE
UNIVERSE WORKS.
ONE VIEWER SAYS HE'S NOT FIT FOR
THE JOB.
WHY?
SCIENCE-DOUBTING, ULTRA RIGHT
WING CONSERVATIVE" AND OUGHT TO
BE REPLACED BY EITHER A
SCIENTIST OR, MAYBE BETTER, AND
ACTOR.
WHAT'S HIS RESPONSE TO THAT?
HE JOINS US IN STUDIO WITH THAT
>> IF ONLY WE COULD GET AN
ACTOR.
>> Tucker: SOMEONE WITH
AUTHORITY.
SOMEONE WHO RETURNS FOR A
LIVING.
WHO IS THIS PERSON, BY THE WAY?
>> I THINK HER NAME WAS REBECCA
JUST KIND OF CRUISE AROUND AND A
JUST KIND OF CRUISE AROUND AND D
JUST KIND OF CRUISE AROUND AND N
AX TO GRIND.
YOU KNOW HOW IT WORKS, ANYBODY
CAN SAY ANYTHING TO ANYBODY
NOWADAYS.
I GENERALLY WELCOME CRITICISM.
IN FACT, I KIND OF CREATED.
BUT THIS WOMAN ACTUALLY REALLY
GOT MY ATTENTION BECAUSE SHE
COPIED EVERYBODY, TAGGED
EVERYBODY, INCLUDING MY BOSSES
AT THE PRODUCTION COMPANY, MY
BOSSES AT THE NETWORK AND SO SHE
ESSENTIALLY SAID THAT BECAUSE
SHE HAD AN OPINION OF WHAT MY
OPINIONS MIGHT BE ON CERTAIN
THINGS, THOSE OPINIONS OF HER
OPINION REGARDING MY OPINION IT
MIGHT NOT NECESSARILY BE
COMPLETELY CONGRUENT WITH THE
OPINIONS OF SCIENTISTS THAT MAY
OR MAY NOT WEIGH IN ON VERY
SPECIFIC TOPICS REGARDING THE
WORKINGS OF THE UNIVERSE.
I'M THE NARRATOR OF THE SHOW.
I DON'T IMPROVISE, I WALK IN, I
SIT DOWN AND I TALK AND A CRISP,
WELL MODULATED BARITONE AND TELL
YOU ABOUT SUPER KNOW AND
QUASARS, THINGS LIKE THAT.
I MIND MY OWN BUSINESS, I SIP MY
TEA AND A CLIMATE CONTROLLED
BOOTH AND I DON'T --
>> Tucker: YOU ARE NOT TAKING
ANY LIBERTIES WITH THE SCRIPT?
>> THE OPPOSITE OF THAT.
I TAKE ALL THE PAIN THEN, NEW
ONES, AND ANYTHING THAT COULD BE
REMOTELY CONCERNED WITH THE REAL
ATTITUDE OUT OF MY VOICE AND
JUST READ SOMEBODY ELSE'S --
REVEALING.
I'VE WATCHED IT CAREFULLY FOR
MORE THAN 15 YEARS, PROBABLY.
>> THAT'S NOT WEIRD AT ALL.
>> Tucker: I'M GOOD AT
SNIFFING IT OUT.
I'VE NEVER DETECTED A POLITICAL
STATEMENT OF ANY KIND FROM YOU
AT ALL.
YOU PLAY STRAIGHTER THAN ANYONE
>> Tucker: THAT ITSELF IS NO
POLITICAL STATEMENT IT SEEMS
LIKE.
>> THAT'S WHAT'S FASCINATING
ABOUT IT.
I'M NOT SURE HOW WE MEASURE OR
QUANTIFY IT, BUT WE DO AND
THERE'S A MYSTERIOUS ALGORITHM
FLOATING AROUND SOCIAL MEDIA
THAT FOR A LONG TIME, IF YOU
SAID THE WRONG THING, YOU HEARD
ABOUT IT QUICKLY.
NOW IF YOU DON'T SAY THE RIGHT
THING YOU HEAR ABOUT IT
INSTANTANEOUSLY.
IT MAKES THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE WHOLE TOPIC NOTHING SHORT OF
FASCINATING.
IN FACT, I THOUGHT OF YOU WHEN I
WAS RESPONDING TO HER, WHICH I
DID IN ABOUT 1200 WORDS.
I WAS ON A PLANE, TRAPPED, AND
HAD SOME TIME ON MY HANDS.
I SHARE YOUR VIEW ABOUT SOCIAL
MEDIA.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT WITH REGARD TO
THE WAY IT'S USED.
AND I THINK -- I THINK ONE DAY I
WILL BE BACK YOU'RE TALKING TO
YOU ABOUT THE PARALLELS BETWEEN
THE SECOND AMENDMENT AND THE
WHAT I MEAN TO SAY IS IT'S A
TOOL.
HOW YOU USE SOCIAL MEDIA TODAY
IS A MAJOR CONVERSATION POINT
AND HOW THIS WOMAN USED IT AND
HOW I RESPONDED TO IT AND WHAT I
TRY TO USE IT FOR WHAT THE SHOW
I'M WORKING ON AND HOW OTHER
PEOPLE CHOOSE TO USE IT.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE THE
ISSUE OF OUR TIMES.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T CARE, FOR
WHATEVER REASON, TO SHARE YOUR
POLITICAL BELIEFS, ASSUMING YOU
>> I DO.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T SHARE
THEM.
HOW LONG CAN YOU KEEP THAT UP?
>> I THINK INDEFINITELY, BUT
QUESTION ON FACEBOOK OR
ANYWHERE.
THE DIFFERENCE IS IF YOU ARE
GOING TO ARGUE, I RUN A
YEAR.
AS YOU KNOW WE RAISE MONEY FOR
WORK ETHICS SCHOLARSHIPS AND IF
YOU WANT TO BE TAKEN EVEN
REMOTELY SERIOUSLY, NOT JUST AS
A NARRATOR FOR A SHOW YOU DIDN'T
WRITE BUT AS THE CEO OF A
FOUNDATION WITH THEIR NAME IN
ARGUE FROM THE MIDDLE.
YOU LOOK AT THE FACTS AS BEST
YOU CAN, YOU ASK FOR EVIDENCE,
WHICH IS THE FIRST THING I DID
WITH REBECCA.
HER ACCUSATIONS WERE VERY CLEAR,
BUT FOR A PRO-SCIENCE PERSON HER
CASE WAS CONSPICUOUSLY VOID OF
WHAT YOU MIGHT CALL PROOF.
YOU CAN HAVE A GOOD TIME AND
CHALLENGE PEOPLE IN A GROWN-UP
WAY TO AT LEAST, AT LEAST CREATE
THE ILLUSION OF PERSUASIVENESS.
BUT IF YOU CAN'T DO THAT THEN
YOU PROBABLY OUGHT NOT OWN AN
OPINION.
>> Tucker: I'M NEVER GOING TO
FULL OF PEOPLE WHO CAN'T WAIT TO
SHARE THEIRS.
>> AN ISLAND IN A STORM.